[Music]
the kids are fantastic
the Douglas legacy is thriving thanks to
Michael Douglas and Catherine zeta-jones
his kiddos
here's Catherine and her mini-me
daughter Cara's striking a pose on Town
& Country September cover inside the mag
the 15 year old dishes on trying to
establish her own identity outside of
her famous fam quote when I was younger
I didn't like the idea of having his
name attached this kind of douglass
dynasty stuff i think what bothers me
the most is that people think i don't
work hard for it adding it's quite the
contrary i feel like i need to
constantly prove myself to people that i
am not just my parents daughter while
Cara's plans to follow in her parents
acting footsteps she wasn't always a fan
of the limelight as a child quote I used
to get really upset paparazzi would jump
on the subway and sit right in front of
me some level of Fame was inevitable for
cars and her older brother Dylan but mom
Catherine says she feels confident they
can handle anything
thanks to their upbringing quote there's
nothing worse than a privileged kid
without manners I drilled it into them
like boot camp I'm probably one of the
happiest women in the world for so many
reasons
you
[Music]